en este vídeo asignaremos carga formal
al nitrógeno y solo para recordarte la
definición de carga formal la carga
formal es igual al número de electrones
de valencia en un átomo libre - el
número de electrones de valencia en un
átomo enlazado a otra manera de decir
eso es que la carga formal es igual al
número de electrones de valencia que
debe de tener el átomo - el número de
electrones de valencia que el átomo de
hecho tiene en el diagrama asignemos una
carga formal al nitrógeno en esta
molécula y recuerda que cada enlace
representa dos electrones dibujaré los
electrones en estos enlaces para que sea
más fácil para nosotros asignar una
carga formal al nitrógeno así que la
carga formal es igual al número de
electrones de valencia que el nitrógeno
supuestamente debería tener
sabemos que el nitrógeno debería tener 5
electrones de valencia debido a su
posición en la tabla periódica esto es 5
y a eso le restamos el número de
electrones de valencia que el nitrógeno
tiene en nuestro diagrama así que
regresemos al diagrama de puntos y
veamos estos enlaces sabemos que de este
enlace en la izquierda el nitrógeno se
queda con uno de esos electrones y de
este enlace en la derecha el nitrógeno
obtiene uno de esos electrones y el
hidrógeno se queda con el otro lo mismo
pasa con este enlace entre el nitrógeno
y el hidrógeno el nitrógeno obtiene uno
de estos electrones y el hidrógeno
obtiene el otro así que cuántos
electrones tenemos alrededor del
nitrógeno en nuestro dibujo contemos los
esto sería 12
y luego tenemos un par libre de
electrones en el nitrógeno este es 4 y
este 5
en nuestro dibujo el nitro que no está
rodeado por 5 electrones de valencia
ponemos 5 menos 5 lo que es igual a 0 el
nitrógeno tiene una carga formal de 0
continuamos dibujando eso tenemos a
nuestro nitrógeno aquí con nuestros dos
hidrógenos y un par libre de electrones
en el nitrógeno vemos que el nitrógeno
tiene una carga formal de 0 por lo que
podemos ver un patrón cada vez que veas
al nitrógeno con tres enlaces y déjame
resaltar esto aquí 1 2 y 3 3 enlaces y
un par libre de electrones significa que
la carga formal es igual a 0 cuando el
nitrógeno tiene 3
la 6
pero de electrones la carga formal es
igual a cero y algunos veces no quieres
incluir en el diagrama los pares libres
de electrones y puedes dejarlos fuera
podría solo decir bien tengo este dibujo
y sabes que la carga formal del
nitrógeno es cero
y se da por entendido que también sabes
que hay un par libre de electrones en
ese nitrógeno esta es sólo otra manera
de representar la misma molécula dejando
fuera los pares libres porque deberías
saber que están ahí veamos otros
ejemplos donde el nitrógeno tiene una
carga formal de 0 empezaremos con este
ejemplo en la izquierda y si ves este
nitrógeno y sabemos que tiene una carga
formal de 0 veamos cuántos enlaces tiene
tiene usemos rojo aquí aquí hay un
enlace dos enlaces y tres enlaces tres
enlaces con una carga formal de cero
sabemos que debería de haber un par
libre de electrones en ese nitrógeno
podrías dejarlo afuera y solo saber que
está ahí
o podrías dibujarlo así que continuaré
dibujando los pares libres de electrones
en el nitrógeno
tenemos una carga formal de 0 ahora
veamos el de la derecha suponemos que el
nitrógeno tiene una carga formal de 0
veamos cuántos enlaces tenemos aquí aquí
hay 1 2 y 3 tenemos tres enlaces por lo
que aún necesitamos un par libre de
electrones si quisieras mostrar el par
libre de electrones podrías incluirlo de
esta manera y observa que esto le da al
nitrógeno un octeto de electrones
alrededor de él cuenta los hay 2 4 6 y 8
el nitrógeno tendrá un octeto y recuerda
que podría solo omitir ese par libre de
electrones y se da por sentado que si
vemos que el nitrógeno tiene una carga
formal de 0 hay un par libre y muchas
veces no queremos tomarnos el tiempo de
incluirlo en el diagrama así tenemos
carga formal a otro nitrógeno por aquí
abajo
cuál es la carga formal del nitrógeno
ahora dibujemos nuestros electrones cada
enlace tiene dos electrones
los dibujos de esta manera y la carga
formal en el nitrógeno es igual al
número de electrones de valencia que
supuestamente tiene el nitrógeno el cual
sabemos 5 escribo un 5 aquí y a esto le
restó el número de electrones de
valencia que el nitrógeno tiene
realmente nuestro dibujo así que para
estos enlaces el hidrógeno obtiene un
electrón y el nitrógeno obtiene 1 para
cada uno de estos enlaces esto nos
permite ver que hay 4 electrones
alrededor del nitrógeno aquí hay 12
y 4 en nuestro dibujo el nitrógeno solo
tiene 4 electrones alrededor de él
esto sería 5 menos cuatro lo que nos da
una carga formal de más 1 es como si el
nitrógeno perdiera un electrón de
valencia debería tener 5 y aquí solo
vemos 4 alrededor de él es como si
hubiera perdido un electrón de valencia
es más 1 el valor de su carga formal
déjame volver a dibujar eso tenemos
nuestro nitrógeno con 4 enlaces
hidrógeno
el nitrógeno tiene una carga formal de
más 1 así que tenemos otro patrón en el
cual pensar aquí incluyamos eso en el
diagrama tenemos 1 2 3 4 enlaces y 0
pares libres de electrones cuando el
nitrógeno tiene 4 en la 64 enlaces y 0
pares libres
pero pares libres de electrones ya hemos
visto que la carga formal es igual a 1
así que veamos algunos ejemplos donde el
nitrógeno tiene una carga formal de más
el ejemplo en la izquierda podemos ver
que hay cuatro enlaces y no hay pares
libres en ese nitrógeno así que la carga
formal es de más 1 aquí en la derecha
pasa lo mismo hay un enlace dos enlaces
tres enlaces cuatro enlaces y ningún par
libre lo que significa que hay una carga
formal de más uno en el nitrógeno
finalmente tenemos un hidrógeno un
nitrógeno más al cual asignarle carga
formal veamos este de aquí dibujemos los
electrones en los enlaces aquí hay dos
electrones y aquí hay dos electrones
cuál es la carga formal en el nitrógeno
la carga formal es igual al número de
electrones de valencia que el nitrógeno
debería tener el cual sabemos es 5 y a
eso le restamos el número de electrones
de valencia que el nitrógeno realmente
tienen nuestro diagrama de puntos
otra vez vemos este enlace que le da un
electrón al nitrógeno y un electrón al
otro átomo y por aquí un electrón se
queda con el nitrógeno y un electrón con
el otro átomo y ahora tenemos dos pares
libres de electrones en el nitrógeno
cuánto es el total tenemos 12
45 y 66 electrones alrededor de nuestro
nitrógeno
5 - 6 nos da menos 1 una carga formal de
menos 1 y continuamos dibujando
nuevamente eso podemos dibujarlo por
aquí un hidrógeno con dos pares libres
de electrones y acabamos de ver que
tiene una carga formal de menos 1 si
quisiera no dibujar los pares libres de
electrones podría hacer eso podría solo
dibujar n iv h aquí y poner una carga
formal de menos 1 y debido a ese patrón
deberías saber que hay dos pares libres
de electrones en ese nitrógeno déjame
dejar claro el patrón aquí el patrón
para una carga formal de menos 1 en el
nitrógeno serían dos enlaces aquí
tenemos dos enlaces y dos pares libres
de electrones cuando el nitrógeno tiene
dos
la 6
pérez de electrones el nitrógeno debe de
tener una carga formal de menos 1 veamos
algunos ejemplos de eso aquí abajo
tenemos al nitrógeno sin pares libres de
electrones dibujados pero sabéis que
este nitrógeno tiene una carga formal de
menos 1 porque te lo está diciendo aquí
cuantos enlaces tenemos aquí hay un
enlace y aquí está el otro enlace
tenemos nuestros dos enlaces pero no
tenemos nuestros dos pares libres
dibujados podría solo saber que están
ahí y continuaré agregando los aquí aquí
está un par libre de electrones y aquí
está el otro par libre de electrones en
ese nitrógeno observa que eso le da ese
nitrógeno un octeto de electrones aquí
en la derecha hagamos lo mismo sabéis
que este nitrógeno tiene una carga
formal de menos 1 por lo que sabes que
debería tener dos enlaces y 2
libres de electrones aquí podemos ver a
los dos enlaces cierto eso se hace cargo
de la parte de los dos enlaces y si
tiene una carga formal de menos uno debe
de tener dos pares libres de electrones
podemos incluir en el dibujo esos dos
pares libres o podemos omitir los
dependiendo de lo que intentas mostrar
en tu diagrama